avez vous toujours eu envie de voir un
petit truc grossir c'est très sexuel
marais tout de suite [ __ ] le quiproquo
autour on discute et on retrouve sur ce
live dub trio ça finit en yokohama
gardien c'est pas pour rien il paraît
que ça y ressemble énormément on va
s'appeler on voit la jouer sobre on va
s'appeler on va la jouer sobre
apparemment on est juste un petit verre
il faut ramasser ces points lumineux
pour grandir et réussir à tuer d'autres
gens c'est la toute première game que je
fais de ma vie ok alors oui il veut
avancer reculer je marche le bas on lui
aurait fait plus tôt fait qu elle est
d'accord je pense à phoenix et de
s'enrouler autour du bec quoique ma
[ __ ] de serpent aurait envoyé lui son
pseudo c'est de l'amour c'est le coeur
moi les gens en choeur ok c'est pas on
va la jouer sobre
je lui ai offert mon corps m'a fait
plaisir
oh là là c'était exceptionnel c'était un
homme je suis désolé vignettage sors de
ce corps trop fort en volant de ce
serpent vraiment oui je te vois le tabou
bâtard et mamie bien il a mangé j'ai
bien bu tout c'est abusé comment les
gens vont très vite faux jumeaux carte
de la sonata ollier a échappé en lui si
on peut le
j'ai voulu dévoiler ces données il est
trop fort l'asticot blanc la calme toi
aussi tu as ta est rétrécie en fait
qu'on accélère roquettes c'est lui le
mec trop fort avec les tout-petits
maintenant tiens ça prendra thank your
way to vollèges de tuer les voilà sa
part sur du congo va pas se mentir on
est combien thiem on n'est pas dans le
top 10 mais c'est ça fait tout peut
jouer en moins d'une seconde ses habits
et les petits comme ça faire attention
regardez regardez j'ai choqué nommé
qu'il a tenté un assaut intel a rien à
perdre il est tout petit tu vois [ __ ]
j'me suis baiser éviter plus on va la
jouer fdp je suis tellement vert voilà
je suis blomet c'est là on apprécie
l'humour est arrivé extra il fait exprès
ouais ouais je vais carrément de mm tu
te donne la peine pour moi quoi [ __ ]
acheter sorti une phrase de haineux là
c'était j'ai adoré mes mondiaux avec oui
mais son corps ne s'arrête jamais la
love academy ko il s'est fait bouffer ou
c'est faux mais bien tenté mais wata
mais en plus ils apparaissent comme
squeeze avec son corps comme pour me
narguer moi j'adore chasser les mecs nul
genre lui chars sommes intégral elle ça
me fait 100 fois plus âgé qu'elle séduit
c'est lui qui m'a tuer tout à leurs
barrières je te vois ta bouffe pierre
battah retient raf fait le mec pas
séjourner sur ce à quoi
comment te plaît ce matin cédric ça je
suis désolé d'avoir crié telle une femme
à léo on les entoure les entoure si le
plan est georges attend ils encerclent
ôtez moi je l'encerclé lui à l'est
d'alger l'a compris et partagé la masse
frères wes aux corses à rennes avec sa
fusée en lui la noue là le gros rouge là
avec la collaboration d'un collègue
hall a explosé le sale bâtard sa part
sur un essai ciao amigos
c'est fini pour toi valentin alors
arrête valentin allez allez au revoir
valentin on sape au passé non mais non
mais matteo j'ai pas fait gaffe en plus
le nom d'un enfant de 6 ans et humiliant
oh là là oh [ __ ] on espère juste un
chouïa
j'adore comment ça sent j'aime trop
apprécié julien lutte
ce jeu est sponsorisé par stromae il est
formidable
ça c'est abusé mais j'ai failli l'avoir
tu fais quoi mais je fais 2 mm tu fais
quoi tu veux faire la course avec aulas
battle de beat walti à lui si on l'a on
se met tellement bien
salut jackson on s'est mis bien baisse 9
d'europe
non mais c'est pas possible j'ai parlé
comme un attardé c'est génial alors lui
voyez lui le gros là ils se méfient pas
d'un petit asticot comme nous et
pourtant qui ce qui devrait
ah c'était l'euromillions on a eu nos
beaux jours on va pas se mentir tout à
l'heure c'était c'était l'apogée de
notre carrière
là on commence à se faire oublier il ya
des nouveaux certains plus compétents de
cuillé ceci est à moi
il fallait que ma tante eux feront qu tu
pourras pas trop par contre tu t'es tu
es mon grand par contre toi
ah ah ah il a feinté bien joué au avec
le bout de la kia raté ma gueule voilà
là je suis invincible je suis sur mac
eux ne me faites pas chier un ya eu
beaucoup de morts l'a eu beaucoup de
morts oh la la
ceci est clairement plus beau jour de ma
vie lui si on en sait peu mais qu'on se
met trop bien
[ __ ] les quatrièmes au sur ce move de
folie on est 3e on y croit on pense aux
copains aux oui
non
au moins jusqu'à 27 vidéo sur slide un
point you voilà le agazio de la longueur
n'hésitez pas à laisser vos influences
nous retrouver dans une prochaine merci
d'avoir regardé peut-être gros frais
vidéo sur ce laser croyons en notre
objectif est d'être premier un jour ne
l'oublions pas sont hôtesses de
prochaine deux portez vous bien chaude
pisse